hi everybody
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today to our
benjamin and barbara zucker lecture
series the first one of 2022
please make sure to sign up for the
yipsa mailing list on the yipsaw website
we have a lot of great talks planned for
this semester
so today's speaker
gregory jones katz is an american
historian based at the chinese
university of hong kong shenzhen
he earned his phd from the university of
wisconsin-madison
greg works in the fields of american
intellectual and cultural history the
history of higher education and the
global history of the humanities his
first book deconstruction an american
institution was published in 2021 so
just recently uh with the university of
chicago press gregg's scholarly work has
also appeared in history and theory
analyse and critique rethinking history
and modern intellectual history he's
committed to public facing scholarship
and has written for the los angeles
review of books the chronicle of higher
education and other mainstream outlets
so just a word about how things are
going to work today greg will speak for
about 35 minutes then we'll open it up
for questions from the audience please
submit your questions using the q a
feature uh at the bottom of your screen
the chat function is disabled and i
can't see you so i won't know if you
raise your hand
but i will ask questions that you submit
using the q a function
uh we'll end promptly at 6 pm greg's
title today is challenging humanism jews
theory and yale during the closing
decades of the 20th century so please
join me in welcoming greg
come on terrific hi okay i'm going to
mute myself now and you can take it away
thank you
thank you maurice for
inviting me to tonight
for my talk uh thank you to the yale
program for the study of anti-semitism
um and thank you um to everybody in
attendance um i'm going to be speaking
um
tonight about how jews deployed theory
at yale um this paper is derived from a
forthcoming article in the journal's
jewish social studies and it's part of
an evolving and larger study on the age
of theory its production consumption and
dissemination
informed the changes at the yale
university and across american higher
education then decentering the the white
male and christian european perspective
pioneering jews in the late 1960s and
1970s first reworked philosophical
principles of literary scholarship and
then helped inaugurate an array of
curricular and intellectual changes
with their anti-humanist often
de-christianizing work jews at yale
theorized and while doing so also
enlarged the purview of humanities
programs and aided the establishment of
various departments and fields of study
this story is important for several
historiographical reasons
dan oren in 1985 provided a rich history
of how jews strove to quote join the
club
building on orange study this talk
explores the intellectual consequences
of part of this movement
this talk also explores how jews
curricular expansions in the 1970s
contributed to what david hollander has
described as the desacralization of
academic culture
finally i aim to eliminate illuminate
how jews deployments of theory shaped
humanistic tenets that informed the
americanization of the holocaust a
process through which the holocaust was
established as a key reference point in
american culture and became a central
event of modern american jewish history
by the mid 20th century a christian
protestant culture in norms was
entrenched in american universities from
the 1970s and 1980s jews at yale
developed theory from the social
standpoint of exclusion as a tool to
challenge the existing order
theory gerald graf has observed is what
erupts when one when what was once
silently agreed to in a community
becomes disputed forcing its members to
formulate and defend assumptions
theory here in this talk denotes what
jews questioned and then reformulated
about humanism but not just making the
explicit of assumptions about humanism
theory is also a way of interacting with
it which produces new knowledge and does
not conserve traditions as such jews
challenges of humanism at yale by using
theory were anti-humanist though these
challenges generated knowledge that
reformed established anti-humanist
traditions
this project was sometimes thus an
interpretive mode
and sometimes a mood emanating from
exclusion and the marginalization as
jews
by the mid-1960s western intellectuals
were exposing the idea of universal man
to be part of christian european
ideology while authors pondered this
crisis of man jeffrey hartman who many
here uh have perhaps heard of and some
some here worked with i had the honor of
spending several afternoons talking to
him about his life and work
while while pondering this crisis of man
jeffrey hartman explored the humanism
espoused
in poetry and prose
a half a century later his debt his
death in 1916 was widely observed it was
noted hartmann's birth in frankfurt
germany on august 11 1929 how he was
sent on kindred transport by his family
to england in 1939
how he was returned how he was reunited
with his mother in new york city in 1946
eventually attending yale where he was a
faculty member for four decades
hartman quote took in the romantic poets
judaic sacred texts holocaust studies
deconstruction the workings of memory
even the very function of criticism
itself but looking back on his career in
the early 2000s hartman observed quote i
suspect i am at heart and essayist
always finding something of basic human
and social interest
the circumstances for this kind of work
were far from propitious
at the end of the 19th century jews were
excluded from english departments whose
members often thought themselves as
defenders of quote-unquote civilization
with the study of english literature as
a way to inculcate culture that is
anglo-saxon christianity
anti-semitism remained rampant during
the interwar years but its decline in
explicitness after world war ii helped
build help open opportunities for jewish
men
jews at yale did not do not fare well
true since the university's
establishment in night in 1701 hebrew
was required and from the 1800s jews
attended and worked there hartman was
not the first tenured jew in yale's
english department though the university
did maintain a quote unquote genteel
resistance to jews after the end of the
second world war
three academic generations would combat
the exclusion of quote-unquote the jew
from humanist ideals
this project's prospects were initially
unclear when members of yale english
aligned with aligned literary education
with the inculcation of christian
beliefs before world war ii professor
chauncy tinker quote summarily vetoed
consideration of jewish american lionel
trilling for professorship
jews tinker decided quote lacked the
cultural and religious background
necessary for the teaching of literature
the inclusion
of jews in yale english was slow
impetus came from the from legislation
such as connecticut anti-discrimination
laws in the 1960s and the 1964 civil
rights act a more approximate cause for
the change for these changes for changes
came from kingman brewster who appointed
who appointed president of yale
university in 63 asked admissions staff
to remove the last relics of
discrimination against jews and other
minorities
the transformation of the student body
started with the university's
recruitment from public schools by the
late 1960s the homogenous quote unquote
yale undergraduate experience was over
but that was all a long way off when
charles fields jr the first ten year
tenured jewish scholar in yale english
challenged in a 48 book narratives of
american literature that justified the
self in puritan identities
but it was harold bloom close friends
with hartman and who become one of the
most famous american literary critics
who first directly while yale english
his second tenured jewish critic
challenged the christian man constructed
out of yale literary formalism
born in 1930 bloom was raised in a
jewish speaking household in the bronx
after receiving his undergraduate degree
from cornell in 51 self-proclaimed
street fighter earned his phd in yale
english in 1955.
bloom called the department quote an
anglo-catholic nightmare
i walked out of a lecture he he once
wrote by tinker soon after it began
because it devoted itself to the
assertion that john milton's poem in
every way transcended the barbaric
hebrew text
bloom responded and his subversions of
yale new critics work were part of a
movement by jewish scholars who seemed
to read their own situation into the
romantic sympathies with outcasts exiles
and outsiders
in shelley's myth making published in 59
bloom embraced jewish philosopher martin
guber's i vow concept of relationships
to trace the mytho poetic power of percy
shelley's poems
uber provided a foundation for jewish
humanism that countered the prevailing
anglo-christian communism this
alternative stressed how all quote
philosophical naturalistic humanistic
ethics are inadequate that jewish
religious texts offer a more compelling
basis for ethical conduct
entering yale's comparative literature
doctoral program in the early 1950s
jeffrey hartman similarly aimed to
antithetically navigate yale formalism
and its christian culture the measured
hartmann judged yale english as
possessing a quote severe evangelical
atmosphere coming up through complete
comparative literature and interested in
european poetics hartman appreciated um
the yale new criticism as quote
something small within a much larger
pedagogical and cultural enterprise
his graduate education instilled
students with the belief in the harmony
of european humanist culture and the
need to quote affirm its literary
inheritance
in the unmediated vision published in
1954 hartman read passages from european
poets to show that a common striving for
a poetry which mediated between its
readers and direct experience was a
modern development in literary history
one that yells new critics ignored
but the christian inflicted song
remained the same when he started
teaching yale at yale in 1955 with
restrictions on the number of jewish
students enforced under an admissions
quota and excluding one secular
philosopher no tenure jewish teachers in
the school's humanities departments
hartman's next book rethought parameters
of humanism in that short short 1960
text harmon argued that french writer
andre melrose quote novel show that he
was one of the first to consider art and
the heritage of western culture as very
special weapons in an era of ideological
warfare
marilla's aim was to quote reconstruct
faith and humanism lost because
humanistic philosophies
failed to produce politically effective
man of action
for hartmann the key to reconstructing
faith in the political and intellectual
foundations of humanism is a new kind of
quote liberal hero an intellectual or
artist capable of political action to
preserve man's free access to his
cultural heritage but also capable of
withdrawal from action when this end is
achieved
hartmann's investment in revised
humanism was then displaced to various
outlets
after denial of tenure at yale in 61 he
assumed professorship at the university
of iowa
but when in 1967 harmon returned to yale
for a joint appointment in the english
in complete he returned to a school more
ready for confrontations with christian
metaphysics
while aiming to seize authority from his
literary critical forefathers bloom
himself offered only clues about his
aims as in the revised 1970 preface to
his 1961 book the visionary company
there bloom implicitly connects jewish
traditions with the radical miltonic
romantic protestant literary tradition
by showing the latter's reverence for
the former's biblical prophecy
bloom's romantics articulated quote a
way of seeing and of living a more human
life
romantic poetry quote either liberated
man from his fallen condition or more
compellingly made him see that this
condition as an unimaginative fiction
hopeful restorative and subversive of
his yell new critical fathers were
bloom's romantics a group followed a
group who followed in the poetic
footsteps of the jewish prophets
retirements or deaths during the first
half of the 1970s of yale english's
senior members encouraged scholars to
contest literary humanism
the challenges that emerged in yale
english included jews who rolled his
rose to senior positions including
harvard and spring and of junior rank
leslie brissman argued in his first book
published in 1973 quote that the
romantic fascination with john milton is
a matter of choice rather than as
bloom-headed anxious obligation
howard felbern extended
deconstructionist theories to the study
of shakespeare in 1972.
these pioneering jews rewritings
dovetailed with jews theoretical work to
revise humanism and were part of a
larger post-60s burst of approaches that
subverted the normativity of knowledge
and culture
bloom used theory to blaze a quite
heterodox path
an anxiety of influence published in
1973
bloom developed and nietzsche's freudian
theory is using it to show that a great
poet refracted of revered precursors
verse
t.s eliot argued that great poets
achieved access to the literary
tradition by honoring their antecedents
via quote a continual self-sacrifice a
continual extinction of personality but
bloom's strong poets freed their own
artistic voices by misreading and
concealing their debts to their
ancestors quote the history of fruitful
poetic influence is a history of anxiety
and self-saving caricature of distortion
a perverse willful revisionism
in bloom's psycho poetic universe
literary history as a sequence of
courteous revision was but a naive
humanist fantasy
while bloom's de-christianizing
contribution was a personal vendetta of
sorts hartmann's hartmanns assumed a
more community oriented and explicitly
jewish direction
after budget crunches of the early 1970s
and amidst the destabilizing attacks on
the christian identity that grounded the
identity
of older scholars yale's humanists felt
their community in tatters a response to
this grim situation had come in the form
of a council in 73 which hartman shared
that addressed the fragmentation of
community
yet hope springs eternal yell english
and discerning onlookers saw a critical
group of merge with hartman rising to
senior rank and yale english
bloom's revisionist theories
crystallized in kabbalah and criticism
in 1975.
a text from 1975 derived from his
university-wide delivered devayne
lectures at yale
while most jews spoke cautiously about
their origins in the 1960s and 70s here
was the first critic in the english
tradition a half decade before the rise
of the new christian right and on the
heels of the 1973 arab-israeli war not
simply asserting not simply asserting
his jewish identity but speculating that
a mystical jewish tradition rested at
the heart of western culture
bloom theorized that the medieval
systems of cabalis moses cordovo and
cabalist isaac lorea showed that all
great post-meltonic poems were
determined by the anxiety of influence
and follow patterns laid down by the
rabbis
yale critic w k wimsat famously equated
the works inner formal harmony with a
christian moral and aesthetic worth
bloom though decreed poems obtain the
illusions of metaphysical presence unity
form or even meaning from other poems
student gossip undergraduates wrote
wrote that bloom's divine series
represents his attempts to defy the new
critics at yale
yale's 1977 offer of his presidency to
then dean at harvard henry ryazovsky
symbolized how far the school had come
the mainstreaming of jews like women and
other minorities into yale's humanities
departments also involved a
countervailing force against
discrimination a merit-based academic
culture to keep pace with peer
institutions yale turned to more quote
unquote objective
criteria for appointment and rewards to
the benefit of excluded demographic
groups
jews uses of theory at yale intersected
with the diversification of the faculty
and student population
around the same time as the religious
right gained in providence and after the
1970s resurgence in the academic study
of judaism a growing number of jews who
earned senior faculty ranked status in
humanities departments at yale became
invested in religious discourse and
radicalized practices of judaism
hartmann's interest intersected with the
push among yale faculty began in 1978 to
refurbish the school's judaic studies
program the efforts resulted in the
establishment of an undergraduate major
in 1980
the prominence of yale's department of
religious studies faculty argue meant
that the university was quote
obliged to set the pace for effective
and responsible graduate study in the
neglected area
the subsequently founded judaic studies
program was to pursue humanist goals as
quote the jewish experience of proposal
reads is co-terminus in space and time
with the experience of western man in
general
hartman was appointed co-chairman of
genetic studies in early 1981
he thought it was a quote variant of
opening the literary canon to a learning
tradition as old as rome and athens
yellow judaic's study programs was
initiated when anti-humanist theories
were descended in the american academy
while jews use theory to revise humanist
aims
associated with the development drive
for judaic studies was the funding of an
archive at yale to house the holocaust
survivors film project
the project will be institutionalized by
way of psychoanalytic theories but it
emerged in part out of work undertaken
during the mid-1970s by the new haven
jewish community which in 1977 completed
a holocaust monument america's first on
public land in new haven
the nationwide holocaust memorial
culture constructed through editorials
newspaper articles and correspondence in
the immediate post-war period had thus
begun to shift into a different mode of
public remembrance
new haven's holocaust monument
exemplifies this change in the 1960s the
american public's attention was only
infrequently drawn to the jewish
community of holocaust survivors
tv minister tv miniseries holocaust was
the first major tv event that would
upset survivors who believe that
massified and under theorized
representations of the holocaust risked
establishing a moral paradigm more
exploitative than educational
such a view of televised portrayals of
the holocaust informed a 1979 discussion
on channel 8 in new haven of a
documentary about the new haven
holocaust memorial
local filmmaker laurel vlock invited
dory loub a child survivor and new haven
psychiatrist to participate
they speculated that survivors might be
prepared to document the stories
vlog and lau began filming four stories
and then the two realized the impact the
recordings would have if shared widely
an early 1980 proposal to garner support
for the new newly established holocaust
survivalist film project also explained
the urgency behind the recording
endeavor quote
the overriding consensus of jews
everywhere is that we must never forget
what happened that our children must be
taught again and again to remember the
holocaust even though they were not
alive during the dreadful era of nazi
germany nevertheless not enough is being
done to record the living memory of
those years
every survivor who dies without leaving
a meaningful record of his or her
experience in the holocaust a record
which can be seen and heard and studied
by jew and non-jew alike for all time to
come constitutes an immeasurable
historical loss
for which we can no longer afford
situating survivor testimony as
antithetical to common representations
of the holocaust and in distinction to
anti-humanist discourses circulating in
humanities departments the public act of
remembrance was felt to be of vital
importance
the hsfps revised humanist ambitions
were stressed during the official
launching
on june 28 1979 at a press conference in
new haven that included new haven mayor
a local jewish and christian clergy
leaders of the new haven jewish
federation a representative
representative representative of the
planned united states holocaust memorial
museum
the president's commission on the
holocaust held the project elie wiesel
the chair of the president's commission
highlighted the cultural link between
the jewish community and humanity quote
the most vital lesson to be drawn is
that auschwitz was possible because the
enemy of the jewish people and a mankind
and it is always the same enemy
succeeded in splitting human society
nation against nation christian against
jew you young against old
the recording of testimonies became an
international effort
when the hsfp found a home at yale in
part two to jeffrey hartman its its
theoretical framework was fleshed out
having evaded the direct impact of the
holocaust hartman felt a responsibility
to help give voice to survivors
one of the first four holocaust
survivors dory laub interviewed was
jeffrey's wife renee who in 1944 was
sent to bergen-belsen
hartman's interest was surely also
stirred by laub whose theoretical manner
of approaching the videotape project
intersected with hartman's
incorporations throughout the 1970s of
psychoanalytic theories to develop a
distinct psycholinguistics
that address the link between words and
psychic wounds
loud theorized that trauma survivors
could mend life only when trauma was
represented
in the hsfp lab's approach a clear
theoretical position that responded to
the visual age that hartman had written
about required listeners to follow the
lead of self-aware survivors
fulfilling the project's goal will
contribute to scholarship as well quote
psychoanalytic work done in survivors
reviewers of a funding application read
is rather scarce when the magnitude of
the phenomenon is taken into account and
the work done was never part of a large
systematic study
despite the manifest historical
pedagogical and scholarly significance
the larger academic community only took
notice of the hsfp after members of the
yale community sanctioned the
undertaking in 1981
while co-chairman of yale's new judaic
studies department hartman helped
inaugurate yale's fortune off video
archive of holocaust testimonies on
november 15 1982 with the original tapes
formally deposited at yale
peter novik argued in 2000 that during
the 1970s quote american jews anxiety
about israel's security and their
viewing israel's situation within a
holocaust framework was the single
greatest catalyst of the centering of
the holocaust in american jewish
consciousness
an avenue for the positioning was was
yale's fortune off archive and this
archive was itself a result of
grassroots efforts in new haven and jews
uses of theory to create a jewish jewish
humanist moment at yale that altered and
created intellectual spaces for jews and
jewish history and culture
president reagan habitually invoked
invoked
judeo-christian values as elements in
the struggle against communism and or
the glue that held american america
together
for different purposes editors of the
1985 inaugural issue of quorum a jewish
journal at yale assessed the jewish
community's yale assistance quote
when a great university they write they
wrote become becomes an important center
of jewish learning the event is in
itself profound commentary on the nature
of the american jewish experience today
great universities were now institutions
where the once virtual identification of
humanism with christian culture had been
shattered with jewish experiences and
religious and poetic traditions embraced
yale president a bartlett giamatti
former professor of renaissance
literature through support behind the
archive while jewish cultural and
religious life cohered at yale yale
hillel and young israel house were
working together
reflecting the new unity oram's
commentary on the link between the
contemporary and earlier american jewish
experience also included a section on
midrash the classical rabbinic tradition
quote
our grandfathers and fathers had their
stories of affliction hope escape labor
but but above all of attachment to
talmud and midrush
orum did not turn to these quote-unquote
resonating words simply to interpret the
past however
even in the new tales of visions and
triumphs in alien worlds the ancient
word threads could still be discerned
with which a god-obsessed people had
tried unendingly
to lend form and substance to the
intuitions of his collective soul
speculation on how ancient word threats
shaped the modern jewish-american
experience was part of academics
theorization going on then about
rhetoric
it do its that itself due in part to the
popularity of what is known as french
theory
american literary critics sympathize
with the rabbinic theories of language
because they too cared for quote every
element of scripture as meaningful
by the early 1980s the quote midrash
theory connection had become a hot topic
in literary studies
contributing to a project on literature
in midrash at the hebrew university of
jerusalem hartmann applied midrashic
deconstructive theories to the textual
fault lines of jacob's wrestling of the
angel
scratching beneath the names listed on
orem's yale faculty advisory board
reveals the scope of jews uses of
monrashik theory to advance their
humanism the board included poet john
hollander in the 80s hollander theorized
that poetry quote in the west was like
rabbinic textual tradition was was like
the rabbinic textual tradition
in a 1988 article he wrote
all poetry is is unofficial midrash at
the very beginning of the western
literary tradition were homer and torah
but the great poetry that followed them
became part of the canon as well
alan goodman had in 1972 sought answers
as to why there were not more major
american jewish poets in the english
literary tradition
while hollinger hollander's colleague
bloom believed in the early 1970s that
american jewish poetry had yet to truly
mature he in 1988 read hollander's spec
spectral emanations collection from 1978
as quote somber american jewish myth
making founded on the metaphor of
menorah from for bloom this poetry
resolved the jewish american
contradiction by combining a sacred
strain and a late romantic worldly
passion
and yet some at yale english members
still found it curious that stars in the
department were interested in jewish
modes of reading
in in 1986 a new york times writer
quoted a
a lapsed baptist
in yale english who thought it odd that
his department that in his department
they were quote jews who found medieval
midrash and kabbalah more or less
compelling modes of interpretation
the manner of of jews contributions to
the theoretical humanist moment were
nominally different in in the french
department at yale
there shashana fellman also on orem's
faculty advisory board explored the
connections between holocaust survivor
testimonies and french theory
thelma received degrees at hebrew at the
hebrew university of jerusalem and in
1970 earned her phd in french literature
at the university
fellman then joined the french
department and in 1973 became its first
tenured woman in jew
in the late 1980s she became a member of
a circle at yale comprised of hartmann
dory laub kathy caruth and others formed
around the concept
of testimony
culminating the interdisciplinary work
and psychiatric psychiatric theories
that centered on the fortune off video
archive fellman labored with yale to
produce in 1992
a key text in the field of traumatic
help mental health and a definitive work
on testimony
in it laob wrote about his work as a
psychoanalyst with holocaust survivors
while fellman used autobiographical
autobiographical accounts of holocaust
and war survivors as well as art
literature and videos to explore the
link between trauma and pedagogy
holocaust survivor testimonies have
become touchstones for tv
representations of the holocaust in the
1980s but in the 1990s feldman's and
others work helped secure the video
archive's reputation by offering a
theoretical complexity and jewish
underpinnings that aided the
establishment of trauma studies
by the mid 1990s in fact jewish literary
critics and scholars who used theory to
challenge humanism had reached the
pinnacle of their profession
as for this jewish movement's local
effects the chauvinism and yale english
was left to historians to explore
while the de-christianization of
literary studies that they're in
interconnected with the establishment of
jewish spaces
in the 1980s and 1990s yale's judaic
studies program exposed future leaders
and clergy to an appreciation of jewish
traditions
yale served as the path to which use and
jewish texts and culture was shown as
integral to the larger society
when the third academic generation jews
earned professorships and positions
across america becoming presidents of
the modern language association
directors and editors of literary
histories and anthologies
judaic studies cultural work created a
background that it helped construct
one legacy linked
to jew's deployments of theory at yale
witness and survivors accounts recorded
for the fortune of video archive for
holocaust testimonies
contributed to making the holocaust a
central reference in american culture
and modern jewish history
consider lawrence langer's book 1991
book holocaust testimonies which the
1995 issue of the new york times
um uh review books listed as one of the
century's 100 most important books
based on eight years of studying oral
testimonies held in the fortune off
archive langer's study theorized that
survivors created quote an impromptu
self in the camps in order to remain
alive
a 27-minute piece for string quartet and
tape steve writes different trains from
1995 creates melodies from loop spoken
phrases from the fortune off archive
these phrases were all reminisces about
their radically different experiences
during the second world war
the piece won a 1990 grammy award in the
classical music category
in these ways another the fortune of
video archive thus played a role in the
americanization of the holocaust when
filmmaker steven spielberg and the showa
foundation prepared to launch a more
extensive holocaust testimony in the
mid-1990s
they sought the help of the fort of
fortune of archive staff including
hartman dana klein and joanne weiner
rudolph
that the video archive informs
the the video archive informed
spielberg's goal to offer an education
and provide blueprints for potential
action about the holocaust and other
genocides
providing an education meadow white met
a widely felt need in multicultural
america for a common moral contract a
broadly held ethical paradigm
historicizing how jews employed fury
yale to institute a revised humanist
movement and mood helps in the
understanding of how the university
became a center for jewish learning
this work can be seen as but one chapter
in the larger age of theory in the
american academy
a story of how jews in concert with
feminist studies post-colonial studies
ethnic studies and other scholars helped
de-center the christian european
perspective
yet what remains certain is that yale's
jews who in mid-century felt excluded
from scholarship in the profession
partook in an informal collective
intellectual enterprise at once
distinctive to the situation and history
of jews and yale and in some ways
illustrative of jews and the increasing
jewish presence in american arts and
humanities departments
in addition to the de-christianization
of literary studies during the 60s and
70s yale's humanist jews
uses of theory helped create jewish
avenues in the 70s late 70s and 80s for
the public remembrance of the holocaust
influencing modern american identity and
modern jewish identity
uncovering a theoretical path at yale
through which the holocaust grows to
prominence in scholarship and the public
and in public awareness of jewish
history and culture this history of jews
theory and yale ultimately might help
illuminate the constructive ways in
which it became foregrounded thank you
all for for listening and um i look look
look forward to hearing your questions
thank you okay thank you uh greg i think
we have a lot to talk about that was a
really um interesting talk and the um
you know there are a lot already a lot
of questions and you know just looking
at the um
list of uh people who are attending i
think there are people who are you know
were part of that history um here so one
thing just off
you know to to um start i was
interested and and happy to hear you say
that the the french department was i'm
i'm a professor of french and um was a
little bit different from um
the english department i would say that
you know fellman
um you know was not the first tenured
jew in the in the french department
there was before her there was uh
georges may who was a very important uh
figure on the yale campus and he was you
know dean in 1968 dean of the college
which was a very you know um and and and
uh victor bromberg also i think was
before
yeah
so i i i met woman uh woman oh the first
woman right okay the first right um but
it is interesting that um the french
department uh would have been more you
know open and i'm wondering like you
know i mean this is my own kind of
interest here but
you know do you think that that's
because um
of a certain kind of intellectual
tradition
you know in france versus um
uh the united states you know is that a
legacy of french universalism being
you know sort of theoretically more open
to jews or is it a sociological thing if
there were just a lot of you know um
jews who studied french like george may
and and pom bear who were european
refugees and um or maybe they weren't
even perceived as jews as much as people
in the english department would have
been they were just foreign you know um
um so
well i think that um it's the legacy
okay
obviously there are many factors that go
into this but if i have to give an
answer i i would say that the legacy um
in this case would be i i imagine just
that the
the legacy in in or the the culture in
yale english
um
developed um has you know
deep traditions
in american culture and i think that
you're right to emphasize the french
emphasis on universalism and the emigre
scholars as well i think when perhaps
more i mean you you know more about this
perhaps more prominent in in french than
in the case of yale english where those
scholars were perhaps coming from um
anglo-american you know uh
like let's say an anglo-american pool
let's say um and so i think that that um
lent
um
and and and
inculcated a certain culture in the
department at the very least
it it it um
created a intellectual culture that that
scholars such as hartman and bloom were
very
um aware of and sensitive
and so
perhaps perhaps um the cultures were not
as as as a stark i mean i would need to
do more work
however
from the perspective of of um um let's
say american jews studying
especially in this case bioromanticism
right um in el english there's all
there's this all it's all loaded with
these these these these meanings um
implicit and explicit yeah you know it
makes me think of a book that i really
like a lot jonathan friedman's book the
temple of culture um and you know where
he he talks about how you know the very
idea of culture in the anglo-american
context which you know we're thinking
about matthew arnold and people like
that is theorized you know as a kind of
opposition to a
racism and um
uh and that is you know there is that
current i think within french culture
too but it's maybe not the the dominant
one so okay so one thing that i a
question that immediately left out at me
and i see some of the um
uh the people in the audience too in one
of your pictures there was of the french
of the i think it was like
lecture there's uh um paul damon is in
the picture and it seems like he's a
kind of
key part of this story and wondering if
you can say a little bit more about his
role in this and and how does that fit
into your argument about um
you know the kind of uh
humanist contesting humanism you know
where does his brand of deconstruction
maybe just maybe tell us a little bit
for those who might not know who was
demone and and what was this scandal
uh so
paul de mon um
a uh
a leading figure in uh what is known as
uh literary deconstruction or or you
know deconstruction uh i mean complete
and french at yale and beginning in i
believe he was hired in 1970 but he
began teaching in 71 um
and until his death in 83 um and then in
um
so he hit so his reputation of his
theory was essentially the reputation
which um in my opinion is
um well the reputation is that his
literary theory was andy explicitly
anti-humanist and nihilistic almost very
destructive of let's say the the core
humanist
values that that let's say college is
supposed to teach and in 1987 uh four
years after his death it was discovered
that he wrote he wrote approximately 200
articles um when he was 20 and 21 years
old in uh in europe he was
a belgian so he's a belgian american and
uh two of them were um
i would explicitly anti-semitic whereas
uh the vast majority of them were
culturally at the very least sympathetic
to
the german dominant the nazi dominance
of of of um of europe and uh this is
very controversial um he was very close
friends with um both harold bloom and um
and jeffrey hartman so
they who who both had their own
different responses to the controversy
um but they they were part of a
intellectual cohort at yale that were
pursuing deconstructive theories
essentially
um
okay there are a few questions i'm
seeing from the audience about um
the concept of of humanism and
anti-humanism
um someone writes um i'm uncomfortable
with the language of anti-humanism it's
smacks of heidigerian roots and can only
be bad for the jews disgust
someone else writes and you can do with
this what you want um how did these
jewish scholars and their intellectual
movement uh engage with concurrent
movements contesting christian humanism
at yale specifically women's studies and
african american studies how would you
characterize the relationship between
these movements
um and then another one must we can join
humanism to christianity admittedly it
was so conjoined uh at the cuatrocento
but humanism now despised by
christianity was the undergirding of the
scientific method the age of theory
contained a good deal of reaction and
posturing demand not to mention
obscuritism someone wrote in
so
these are great questions i'll just
start um
the first one which i believe was about
uh being um uh uncomfortable with the
word anti-humanism
i think was the question i would just
argue um i thought about this i i see i
see this moment um uh with this paper
and what i'm trying to to um talk about
as a dialectical in a way i i see i see
um you know uh
uh you know at the end of their careers
uh for example hartman and bloom are
very comfortable saying i'm humanist i'm
a humanist right
now in the 70s they are
labeled as anti-humanists but i see it
as dialectical in that that some of the
moves that some of these scholars are
making um are um in the name of a
humanism but they are critiquing some of
the assumptions or implicit meanings
that are then loaded with humanism as it
was practiced
in the 50s 60s and 70s
so um i see it as historical in that
sense and not like we could pick we
could pick this work out of its
historical context to say oh
anti-humanist you know it was in the
name of a humanism especially looking
back on on it um um uh but it was
sometimes labeled itself as
anti-humanist um but again the
dialectical um the sort of um movement i
think is important and i had one
sentence in the beginning of my talk
that i think that kind of alludes to
this argument and then i sort of move on
um so that's how i would answer that
um
um so so these are humanists but they
are they are attacking the principles of
humanism in the name of a new humanism
now the default case
i
i don't you know i i think that's more
complicated i i personally um i think
that that's that's and i can't uh i feel
uncomfortable talking about it um with
this project you know um and
that i talked about today um whether
he's an anti-humanist
uh for all time
um is is is a debatable is
probably the case um
um with you know so um and then the
second question i think was that
heidegger is that a question about
heidegger is there are there
heideggerian
connotations to antiques
um heidegger i mean well i mean
so speaking of the two main figures i
looked at bloom and hartman i mean bloom
notoriously
uh said very very uh very funny um but
also aggressive uh comments about how
much he did not like heidegger and all
the heiderian um critics that were
inspired by heidegger even though he was
close friends with bloom was very close
friends with daradah and all these other
figures
um so is there something suspiciously to
gearing about about i mean i think
heidegger does cast a a a long
uh intellectual shadow um that
that um
whether whether for example the case in
bloom
case of bloom whether whether they they
agree with heidegger or not they were
still struggling and dealing with what
had been created in in the aftermath
of of heidegger and also of course
heidegger's um complicity with with the
nazi regime and what that all brings up
and and and you know very serious
very very serious issues so um does it
raise this heidegger yes i mean i think
that it does i think in in in a larger
study um this would have to be addressed
great so i want to um dig down a little
bit deeper
in the question of
the specificity of yale in in your
argument so like
why um
how much of that well i guess there are
two parts of the question like how much
of your story is specific to to yale and
how how if you could say a little bit
more about you know analogous kind of
changes going on in other universities
even other ivs or just other
universities and then you know why
um
some why this happened at yale you know
i i was sensing a kind of line of your
argument that a lot of it had to do with
the contingency of certain personalities
um at yale like just the presence of
bloom and hartman and their
you know the force of their
personalities and um
but you know i wonder if there was also
something about
yale's own history that maybe determined
that or even its geography its place in
new haven i you know i could see lots of
potential
um answers so
so
basically why yell and then and and why
um
what's how were other universities um
grappling or changing or not with with
these changes yeah um well
so a more
i'll start with the 1970s i mean you
know um
yale um and i did not mention this in my
talk you know yale um
you know had their first first um cohort
um of of of women uh undergraduates i
believe admitted in 1969.
um
so um and then um
the
they also um instituted the uh i hope i
get this right the first um oh gosh
um
[Music]
some of the some of the some of the
first ethnic studies departments were
also started yeah so the there's this
larger um
uh moment at least in the 70s post-60s
let's say okay where where some of the
assumptions that that i alluded to you
know the the sort of white male
christian
uh um image of humanism were were being
uh decentered okay um now if you go back
a little further in the 50s and 60s then
you have um uh
that you have the yale english issue
where these are sort of uh
by the as you say the force of
personalities with bloom and hartman
they are the challenging in their own
way
in a more more um
more local issue or more localized um uh
confrontations some some rather um
indirect and oblique i mean you know
they didn't they didn't come out you
know after they cut their phds and sort
of um challenged these issues but it
wasn't until the 70s that
while those other changes at yale were
happening now there's also the issue of
yale um being and again i i should have
written this down um
um i hope my member doesn't doesn't
found me here but you know yale was
founded as a um
seminary originally right so i mean this
goes back hundreds of years so and so
yale has this much longer history of
being a seminary um uh this religious
background um
tied to um you know uh i mean sort of
the new england
new england let's say uh culture um
so um you have that that that much
longer history you have the the 70s that
i mentioned you have yale english um the
more local um issue
and then um you also have the issue of
of yale uh in the post-war uh after
1945 as being a one of the
and known as having the best english
department in the world this is like a
phrase people would throw around um so
to have the best english department in
the world um
combined in the in the 50s and 60s with
all these other issues right you create
this situation especially if you have
let's say these younger scholars such as
bloom and hartman coming through um who
are jewish who are in the best english
department of the world all these other
issues percolating um also
yale of course in the 1970s becomes a
a a a center of uh deconstruction
which
which it was considered um for better
for worse depending on on your your
views um the most advanced
theory of let's say a technique for
reading literature so it becomes this
focal point of deconstruction and theory
the most advanced work being done in the
humanities which usually at that point
came through literature departments so
you have all these factors happening at
the same time um and some longer history
some shorter histories
that i think um
contribute to this moment and um
and ask oh sorry no no go ahead
as to other
universities um well other universities
don't have that's uh
at least quite in the same way the ivys
don't have that
that combination of factors i mean other
ivs such as dartmouth went co-ed as well
i believe cart dartmouth was the first i
i could be wrong um so they're these but
they're not it's not quite it doesn't
have all the other factors that i
mentioned
public universities is a different story
you know university of wisconsin-madison
um has it had uh developed a quite
different relationship because of
anti-discrimination laws is my
understanding um
that were enforced at public
universities whereas you know yale
being private i think it was a different
situation i i i i think um i would need
to do more work on that to be honest
with you so let me let me throw out
uh uh you know um an idea you know which
is that i wonder
whether um
[Music]
the turn towards holocaust studies that
you um talk about in your um talk by
many of the deacon the deconstructionist
critics
um that they make this turn to holocaust
studies
um
and
you know to go back to demand i guess
i've always sort of read that as linked
to that that it was this sort of um the
demand affair this recognition that you
know their colleague um had this kind of
you know complicity you could argue
um
and
i feel like some of those tensions are
very present in shoshana feldman's in
the testimony book especially um and
that there it's almost like a kind of i
don't want to say making amends but
there's a kind of like
or or reconsideration of of the the you
know presence of history and trying to
figure out a way to to do that
theoretically and that the um
what do you what do you think about
well i mean i think you're absolutely
correct i mean well that's correct my my
view is yes uh with the feldman
testimony book i think this is also true
um it's a it's a sincere
rigorous attempt to grapple
with exactly what you said this question
of history that demands theory had
completely bracketed essentially um
uh for all for
professional intellectual personal
reasons um um but i will say i will say
that um
you know many of us many um
yeah many of his former colleagues um
did that as well after the after the
demon affair in 87 however
however hartman um
[Music]
yeah
um
uh hartman um began
um
uh work on his psycho-linguistics he was
working on that in the 1970s and as i
mentioned in the talk he he um and he
had pulled away from what he called
let's say the boa deconstruct
deconstructors um by the late 1970s so
there was already as as a a a
someone just commented there was already
a move among a certain cohort
of deconstructionists
um
towards um
a way to sort of try to reconcile let's
say and i'll put this in quotation marks
anti-historical deconstruction versus
history
that that really
came to public notice
let's say
in terms of publications um
after the demon affair so i think that
that's a little bit of an illusion um so
hartman hartman's work um
goes back and and uh yeah so so i think
but i think you're right nevertheless
nevertheless i think that the the view
stands
that there is a grappling that attempts
to be
and i you know i should i wanted to to
say you know before right when i came on
that you know
just to um credit jeffrey hartman with
the really the you know creation of the
anti-semitism program that were here i
mean i think that it would not um he was
instrumental in setting up this program
uh in 2011 and it probably would not
have been created with without him and
that's like a whole other um
story that we could talk about privately
but he was really and you know we
inherited his a lot of his library um on
books about anti-semitism so just wanted
to acknowledge that so maybe last
question in the remaining time and a few
people have posed it and it occurred to
me
too
if you could say something about um
the current
uh campus dynamics and um someone one of
the uh
people
the questions put it very well that
you know jews
used to be seen as you know um
these kind of renegades uh you know um
kind of uh challenging accepted norms
and now arguably are seen as uh part of
the establishment uh you know not um
you know kind of just white basically at
yale now and so i don't know can you can
you say something about about that and
kind of current campus dynamics
not at yale necessarily but
uh
so that's that's really tough for me to
answer to be honest with you um i i uh
i'm not sure i'm not sure how to answer
that and the reason why um is because um
i have lived in china since 2016
and i think that that i i i
i mean i i understand the question but
but um
i i think it's a great question how the
the switch from renegade to
uh let's say establishment or i'm not
sure how you want to put it but what
happened um
um
oh gosh i i i i'm really sorry i i i i
no no no i mean it's it's an interesting
um
you know and and and you know to kind of
think about you know the place of um
uh you know judaic studies i mean one of
you know the kind of goals i think of
you know the
our program the anti-semitism program is
to inject you know questions of
anti-semitism and jews into discussions
about race on on campus and so and to
try to think about you know ways to to
do that
um
anyway it's it's um an interesting thing
so can you just say so are you um really
last question how are you thinking about
this project are you seeing it develop
as um
as a book is it like a group uh
portrait is it gonna be focused on yale
or was that talk just for us or how how
are you singing
no i mean i
you know i i i
i have a um an idea for a project about
um
like global theory it's production
at
various sites
in the united states
and then it's dissemination
um
abroad um
and this would be um this is this was
this this was a project that really um
got me really thinking about how and why
that was happening um and so for example
my definition of theory at the beginning
trying to understand
um you know i mean these jews one way of
thinking about it is is they they
formalized the assumptions right they
use these these are techniques that
formalize the wants the assumptions that
existed in the culture around them and
whatever they were in whatever field
they were in
so i see this as part of a larger
project but it won't be focused
on on on yale
although i'm happy to continue um these
were great questions and i i i happy to
um expand this but
but i guess we'll we'll see
okay terrific well thank you so much for
for um sharing your work with us and
thank you to
everyone in the audience and everyone
who submitted questions and as i said i
encourage everybody to go to the ypsa
website and sign up for our mailing list
and we have a lot of other
great programs uh set up for
this coming semester so thanks to greg i
will uh clap for everyone you can't hear
all the clapping but uh it's there and
um see you all at another event sometime
soon
thank you so much